if i put everything on powerpoint slides
and flash them like this
during the class and i'll cover the book
will they learn anything no
they won't learn anything because the
human mind is limited in its information
processing capacity the brain can only
take in so much information at a time
which means a very very high percentage
of that information that you're pouring
out like that is never going to be
absorbed by the students so you're
wasting your time
you're wasting their time
if you back off
don't try to present
so much information and imagine that
you've taught it because you haven't
focus on what is the most important
information
that i'm trying to present in this
particular lecture it's not all equally
important
there are a lot of things which if the
students never saw them it wouldn't hurt
them it's not going to be on the exam
you know it's something that we think
well it would be nice to expose them to
it
but just exposure
is relatively worthless as far as
learning is concerned
and so if you're careful to focus on
what is the critical information that
i'm trying to present in this class
today
and you make sure that you present that
information
and let the other stuff go or leave it
for a reading or something of that sort
and then
critical information you give the
students an opportunity to do something
with it to try it and then get feedback
two minutes later
you're going to see a huge difference in
what the students end up knowing
and you're going to see a huge
difference in those recitations
instead of just seeing the blank faces
and the questions that they're now
asking because they never had a chance
to do it before you're going to see
students who understand something from
those lectures and now you can really
put them to work in the in the tutorials
to try more difficult problems to have
interesting discussions and so forth it
makes a huge difference in the nature of
what you're doing
uh as a professional
yeah so in our native tongue we have uh
one saying which goes something like
this it's a rough translation
you eat less
but you eat well
no that's good